is it fair to say then that lockdowns
were just a mistake yes I don't think
lockdowns in it in a society that's as
unequal as ours could possibly succeed
well have actually been the effects of
these lockdowns 100 million cancer
screenings had been skipped and that's
going to lead to a million people with
later stage cancer that should have been
picked up the the psychological effects
in the U.S
something like one in four young adults
seriously considered suicide in June of
2020. 100 million people is the estimate
thrown into poverty worldwide by the
economic dislocation caused by the
lockdown 230 000 children had died in
South Asia alone it was bound to destroy
the lives of the poor the working class
the you know it is and children it's
exactly what it did the lockdown was
focused protection of the laptop class
instead of focused protection of the of
the of the vulnerable old and that's why
Hospital systems were under stress
because we protected the wrong people
for vaccine mandates
if you are mandating the vaccine you
have failed as a public health agency
because what what that what that means
is there's a substantial number of
people who don't trust you the for young
men the the MRNA vaccines cause
myocarditis at unacceptable rates
one in two thousand one in three
thousand something like that
that is too high
[Music]
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anthem has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Rich are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today among
his very many titles is a professor of
medicine at Stanford University and uh
one of the co-authors of the Great
Barrington declaration Dr J bhattachara
welcome to trigonometry just a delight
to be here thank you for inviting me oh
it's a great pleasure to have you on
we've been meaning to have you on for a
long time uh however for those of our
audience who are not familiar with you
and your role particularly over the last
couple of years uh tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what
has been the journey through life that
leads you here uh sure so I have a
strange background I have an MD and a
PhD in economics of all things
um I've been a professor in the medical
school at Stanford for 20 some years uh
I've written on on infectious disease
policy for a long time uh when covet hit
I sort of came to a different view than
many people I guess
um that the disease was pretty
widespread already uh that there was a
age a very steep age gradient in risk
and risk factors and so we should follow
a very different policy uh than we did
follow the policy that eventually we
label it the Great Barrington
declaration the idea is focus protection
of vulnerable people and then letting
you know children go back to life great
low-risk people get back to life because
the harms and the lockdowns themselves
talk about the strings during our
podcast but the harness the lockdowns
themselves are so bad that you don't
want you just want to avoid them that
document which I wrote with with a
couple people from uh with the with
symmetric Gupta from Oxford and and uh
Martin culda from Harvard that went
viral uh it so anyways I'm sure we'll
talk about that but that that that's
that's my background I've done this kind
of work for a long time
um and been teaching at Stanford for a
long time and you were one of the people
together with sinekra Gupta and others
who were articulating The View during
the the pandemic itself the the main
section of it that uh lockdowns were
very harmful that many of the other
public health policies that were being
pursued were mistaken
um and one of the responses was uh to
ignore you and in fact the sense of any
of the things that were being said so
here we are we can sort of look back uh
and assess how things have gone as you
look back do you think you were right do
you think you were wrong what is your
assessment of how how it's played out I
think um we got a lot right
uh very early so uh we meaning I mean I
was wasn't just me alone there was me
and a very large number of other
infectious disease uh uh epidemiologists
and and uh and other other health policy
people that had shared my view
um so for instance uh in April of 2020 I
ran a study looking at how extensively
the disease had already spread in Santa
Clara County California where I live in
LA county and then another study with
Major League Baseball all around the
country
um we found in LA and in Santa Clara was
that there was three or four percent
prevalence of covet antibodies
um that mean what that means if you have
the antibody that you can talk we can
argue about immunity but that certainly
means that you've been infected and
recovered
um so that means that or that means that
there's a lot of uh a lot more spread
than people had realized it was like 50
times more infections than cases that
meant the lockdown in April of 2020 met
their lockdown could not work like if
you were if you're thinking okay we need
the lockdown we get to zero that was
gone
of course that should not really true we
did we didn't actually end up getting
rid of the disease unfortunately
um uh the uh uh the uh and they've been
like a hundred of these similar studies
that have been done since the the sort
of that verify the same result we found
um okay so sorry to jump in so is it
fair to say then that lockdowns were
just a mistake yes
yeah I think there were I think that the
disease was seated around the world
sometime in probably in Fall 2019 late
fall 2019 could be November could be
December it could be I mean you could
persuade me earlier I don't know the
exact date
um the evidence for this is that uh
there are antibody studies again from
stored blood banks
in uh in Europe in Africa that find
coveted antibodies from stored blood in
Fall 2019. how did it get there unless
someone someone from China went there
um you know of course you got these
massive Vibe breaks in in Italy in
February again Iran in February 2020 it
was too late by the time we locked down
this disease spread so easily
so fast and it just doesn't take a ton
of contact with the air of people
someone's breathing that with with it
that it was not it was far too late to
if the idea was to get the disease down
to zero now if the idea was to get the
disease uh slow the spread so that we
can build Hospital capacity and things
like that a little lockdowns failed at
that too we didn't actually build
Hospital capacity we we did all kinds of
other things
um that that and the there was this like
sense that we should keep locking down
like you know the disease would come and
go based on you know its physics but we
had this illusion of control over the
spread of the disease we could talk more
about why I think lockdowns failed
there's there's a deep social science
reason I think what I feel mainly I
don't think lockdowns in it in a society
that's as unequal as ours could possibly
succeed
and Joe why did we lock down then
why did we follow China's lead i i
because I'm I'm not a great expert on
China but I look at them and I think
yeah that's not probably the way to do a
lot of things really what copy a
totalitarian regime which has got a
disastrous approach to human rights
it was really shocking actually uh so we
um I'm part of this case where we we
actually got to depose Anthony fauci in
the early days of the pandemic he sent
uh one of his trusted aides a man named
Cliff Lane to China on this essentially
this trip that the World Health
Organization organized they came back
from the trip completely impressed that
China had conquered the disease in
January 2020.
now of course there wasn't a lot of
testing going on in January 2020.
um China as you say Francis has this
track record of authoritarian power
that's just alien to the West
at least was only to the West before
before March 2020.
um and so it really it I think it
surprised everybody I saw how this uh
this interview of Neil Ferguson the the
uh the uh the epidemiologist at Imperial
College London talking about the Chinese
uh the Chinese model and his how stunned
he was that that the West actually
adopted he was he was actually happy
about it but it was he was very
surprised
um I think it was fear and panic for
instance at the end of the day people
looked at the Chinese models that oh
gosh it they got rid of it by January
2020 they looked at Italy uh which was a
total mess
um they looked at uh they looked at New
York City and they were just scared I
think fear led us to completely
irrational choices the choices that we
never would have made had we not made
had we not panicked um in March of 2020
Joe why why didn't we look uh because
um correct me if I'm wrong but why I
understood by the by the Great
Barrington declaration is he was saying
look this is a way we've always dealt
with pandemics through centuries this is
the most effective way of dealing with
it this is what we should do why did we
suddenly throw away hundreds of years of
learning how to deal with a pandemic and
try this new approach
I mean I think I I have a couple couple
of things I just told you the one about
fear and panic I think that that's
certainly certainly was like probably
the most important explanation but Jay
that would have been the case always
people would always have been scared in
a pandemic but I think the problem was
like this one looked this one's you know
if you look at the actual infection
fatality rate it's it's more than those
Century pandemics like maybe 1918
I mean so so we're looking at this going
okay this is the big one this is we've
waited a century for this pandemic has
finally arrived
um but there's some other aspects of
this right so imagine I don't know for
certain this is true I but it may be
true that this was a lab leak
from a gain of function work right so
from from from a program of research
aimed at increasing the the infectivity
or or of a of a of the pathogen
what if you're responsible for that
research program and you fear that it's
like out of your lab or out of the out
of a lab that you supported and you're a
major figure like Tony fauci or Francis
Collins or or Jeremy Ferrar I mean
you're going to want to do absolutely
everything you possibly can to like put
the genie back in the bottle
um and you know they don't really have a
lot of social science background they
really don't have a lot of frankly
they're not even many of them are just
lab scientists not really
epidemiologists they don't understand
the uh the limitations of these kinds of
or the harms from these kinds of
interventions it's for them it's just
okay it's a it's a model in that model
you you make sure newborns don't
interact with their moms and all of a
sudden the disease goes away or whatever
um I mean it's just not it's just
incredibly naive so but they but they
but they but they're incentive is to
like let's do everything we possibly can
to to reduce the damage from this thing
that I supported now again I don't know
for certain it's a lively but imagine
psychology of it
but Joe do you also think as well and
if we look at our society now we there's
this belief amongst a lot of people that
science can conquer anything it can cure
any disease we've you know we've
conquered infectious disease we're
deeply a lot of the western civilization
is secular we don't believe in God we
don't believe in religion so if you put
those two things together
why wouldn't you think that you can
conquer this disease surely we can
defeat covert can't we we have science I
mean science has made a lot of progress
on on this disease like we you know the
vaccines the the treatments the
treatment Protocols are way better than
they were in two years or two and a half
years ago
um science works is it's an incredible
thing for understanding the material
world but it takes its time it requires
debate and discussion uh the problem
isn't science so much Francis the
problem really is uh we elevated some
high scientific bureaucrats to the
position of the hype of like high Pope
you got someone like Tony fauci's
telling Rand Paul that uh you know if
you question me you're not simply
questioning a man you are questioning
science itself I think come on that's
just ridiculous I mean you just you know
that's that's it's like a very
antithesis of science that one person
like puts on the mantle of of you
essentially the the high pope of science
science is requires people to like
disagree with each other I'm going to be
wrong I've been wrong lots of times in
my life and then what the but the
wrongness is is adjudicated not by like
some high Pope or high priest it's
adjudicated by you know you you run you
you run a study with some data and a
fantastic study and then it turns out
that my theory was wrong
a beautiful Theory killed by an ugly
fact that's the point of the realm in
science not not like Tony fauci on high
declaring this is the science that's
just nonsense and that's what we've had
through dependence it's Martin cool Dev
wrote about this is like the End of the
Age of Enlightenment the return of the
Dark Age The Dark Age what that means is
um science uh facts are determined by
Authority not by not by you know not not
by data not by reason discussion not by
discussion and debate
and you you mentioned Anthony fauci
several times and I'll be honest with
you I haven't followed the details of
covid uh particularly since in the UK it
was kind of over you might say you know
certainly the public policy measures
that I was so strongly against they kind
of stopped and I think a lot of people
felt the way I did which is I just want
to forget about this and never have to
think about it again I promptly then got
covered again but never mind
um but anyway I haven't had to you I
haven't I haven't been forced to think
about it in the way that I think I was
before where I was going the
government's going crazy they're
introducing all these measures that I I
think are tyrannical frankly I don't
agree with them
um but you you uh you and a lot of
people uh feel I think quite strongly
about particularly Anthony fauci and
some of the actions that he took so
explain to us why why are people so
critical what is the case against
Anthony fauci yeah so first first of all
I was entirely jealous of Freedom day I
was sitting here in the United States
going okay how on Earth you guys you
guys get Freedom day and we get we get
vaccine mandates and nonsense
um right it could be worse you could be
in Canada yes that's true
um I I think the thing about Tony fauci
and and uh and his boss Francis Collins
the reason why they're so important
is because they sit on a top of 45
billion dollars 50 billion dollars of
money that funds every single biomedical
uh scientist of note in the United
States and many in in the UK as well
actually
um and the problem there is not that
itself is not a problem I mean I fully
support uh public support of science
um but but the problem is that if that
person or that set of people then
involves themselves in controversial
topics of Health policy
a lot of scientists will keep themselves
silent
for fear of losing that support and it's
not just money actually because many
people don't know this but like if so I
have a tenure at a medical school at a
top Medical School the um in order to
get tenure you actually have to you have
to you have to get an NIH Grant you have
to earn an IH Grant it's very very
competitive and if you don't um
succeeded that you're not going to get
10 years social status in science
depends on earning the approval of
people like Tony fauci and Francis
Collins
and so when they uh speak up and say
gosh you know this all this other uh all
these other ideas the great branch of
Declaration is nonsense a lot of
scientists are going to take the message
take the hint you know they don't they
they're not directly involved in health
policy they just won't speak up even if
they if they have uh qualms about the
policy
um and uh and some people will you know
it's like uh
you know will someone rid me of the
Troublesome priest kind of thing like
you'll get like people just to you know
ad hoc attacking because they wanted
Curry favor
um
um it's I think uh very very dangerous
to have this kind of power over the
social status and funding of scientists
and then also be so closely involved
with health policy decision making in a
country which is exactly I think what
why Tony facci's coming under such
criticism
and the problem is with this as well
possibly even more serious than that Jay
is how much it damages the ordinary
person's perception of scientists and
doctors where they lose their trust in
them which is a really dangerous place
to be as a society I completely agree it
has been shocking to watch
uh I've been so I you know I do medicine
I I've watched the anti-vaxx movement
with uh with respect to measles and
others before the pandemic and I think
it was mostly just it really was a
fringe movement um mostly people trusted
doctors when they told them that
vaccines work for these diseases
during the pandemic I've seen this vast
explosion in the anti this sort of the
sentiment I'm only one called anti-vaxx
this stemming from that distrust for
instance of scientists and doctors
created by this kind of hubris by
scientists and doctors it's our own
fault
um and and uh it's so to me it's
completely understandable then on top of
that you have these vaccine mandates
which made it you know people that
distrust distrusted the the vaccine now
have to face this decision about whether
they want we're willing to lose their
jobs many did
um it's exploded the distrust in
vaccines generally and the other thing
is that the there was over claiming
about the efficacy of this vaccine
um and you know when scientists get
things wrong they they should have some
distrust there should be some distance I
think what would have gone a long way is
just humility uh by scientists by
doctors instead I mean maybe it's less
so in the UK but the United States I
mean humility was probably the very last
word I used to characterize the response
of our of our Public Health officials
and it also seemed like the the
government and the health authorities
they didn't really treat people like
adults in the sense that if like for
example if you tell me that a vaccine is
a hundred percent safe it's safe I know
you're lying no vaccine is 100 safe
right that it might be 99.99 safe but
but it's not a hundred percent safe and
anyone who claims otherwise is clearly
lying or hiding something and likewise
people who pretend vaccines don't have
side effects or that they have a you
know high levels of efficacy when
clearly they don't it seemed like I
think a lot of the undermining that
you're talking about happened because
actually the authorities refused to be
honest with us and treat us like adults
would you agree I completely agree I
mean in fact you can look at how they
talk about about the the vaccine uh
rollout the actually even the lockdowns
um actually this is in the UK they
actually had a group inside your your
Sage which is the scientific
organization that advises the government
um called the nudge unit the idea is to
manipulate the the people of the UK
um the the use of Behavioral uh
psychology to try to manipulate people
essentially like a propaganda techniques
um and then overstating just exactly
like you said Constantine about about
basic things right so vaccines it takes
a while to to understand the full safety
profile you tested on what fifty
thousand a hundred thousand people in
the trials
um and then but that's then you send it
out to billions you're gonna learn
things about that what the vaccine does
it's not all going to be all good right
so the the myocarditis in young men from
the MRNA vaccines we didn't really know
that from the trials that came out
afterwards and it just takes time I work
on vaccine safety for a living and it
you know it takes decades sometimes to
fully understand certainly years to
promise that you're going to have no
side effects I mean come on that's just
that's just treating people like their
their children
um and then like over promising right
this vaccine is a hundred percent
effective against getting getting the
disease I've Got Friends vaccinated I
got the disease like four months after I
got the second vaccine I got the disease
you can look at the data the randomized
trials clear that they didn't even check
for that
so what were they what were they saying
well why were they over claiming they a
lot of the public health authorities
viewed this as like we have to convince
they were like essentially farmer sales
people we have to convince people to get
this and in the back of their heads they
thought about this vaccine the same way
they thought about the measles vaccine
you get the measles vaccine you're
pretty much not going to get measles
ever again you're just it's a great
vaccine
um I'm not saying it has absolutely no
side effects but it's pretty pretty safe
um and where is this vaccine it just
doesn't have that property it doesn't
stop it protects you against getting
severe disease if you happen to get
covet which is very likely that you will
um but it doesn't stop you from getting
covered
hey Francis do you like Japanese food of
course who doesn't love a bit of sweet
and sour pork lemon chicken sweet and
sour pork and lemon chicken aren't even
Japanese they're Chinese Francis but
when all went to Japan I had sweet and
sour pork was it a Chinese restaurant in
Japan yeah I did wonder why it was
called the Great Wall
[Music]
unlike Francis I've actually been to
Japan it is an amazing country which
Prides itself on combining traditional
Japanese Elegance with the latest in
modern technology and there is no better
example of this approach than kamikotta
knives the knives come in a heavy duty
Ash wood box which makes it a great
present especially with Christmas coming
up the knives are used by Michelin star
chefs all over the world so they're the
perfect Christmas gift if you have a
budding Gordon Ramsay in your kitchen
kamikoto is running a massive early
Black Friday sale right now and is
offering all viewers an extra fifty
dollars off any purchase with discount
code trigonometry go to
kamikoto.com
trigonometry as a trigonometry fan you
can get an incredible deal on a range of
kamikotta knife sets go to kamikoto.com
trigonometry to get an extra fifty
dollars off on any purchase with this
code trigonometry during the early black
Friday sale I bet they're great for
cooking lemon chicken cut
do you worry Jay that when we have
another pandemic because we're going to
have another pandemic that's how you
know such is life that actually such has
been the distrust of that has been sown
within the wider population that you're
going to get a pretty sizable majority
of people are going to be like nah don't
believe you you betrayed my choice first
time why am I going to believe you now I
mean there are still people in Wales
that are really quite upset with Neil
Ferguson the the modeler because of the
the uh the uh mad cow disease they
killed they killed like a very vast
number of of cars because I wasn't
really necessary
um I I think I you're absolutely right
for instance that's exactly what's going
to happen there's now a pretty broad
movement and I I don't even know what
the name to call it but it's it's a
movement that had as its root deep
distrust a deep earned distrust of
Public Health authorities and of
governments acting in the name of Public
Health
um I have to say like there will be
um if when there is another pandemic
there's going to be a big fight over
whether we are re-adopt this kind of
authoritarian approach I'm very afraid
that exactly that's what will happen
that would that the public health
message is we just didn't we didn't lock
down hard enough we didn't use our
police power strongly enough
um and we need to absolutely demolish
these these these crazy Fringe movements
that are that are opposing us I think
that that kind of that's exactly the
fight will happen in the next pandemic
uh should there be uh
authoritarian power applied in this in
the name of Public Health even more than
was applied now that's the only reason
it didn't work versus let's go back to
the old approach which would have worked
let's treat people in a in a democratic
and liberal society as as adult human
beings reason with them use resources
move Heaven and Earth to protect
vulnerable people for God's sakes yes
but also don't disrupt the lives of
other people who are less vulnerable in
ways that harm them and Society
irreparably almost yeah well Jay you
hinted earlier that you thought that one
of the reasons that these approaches
were never going to work in the western
particularly is the inequality the
unequal societies that we have can you
talk to us more about that absolutely so
um what's not just the West is unequal
everyone is unequal I I my my mom was
born in a Calcutta slot my mom looked
worn it grew up in a Calcutta slum right
so it's it's um it's so uh a lockdown if
you were if it's going to work in any
even in any theoretical sense you
basically what the purpose is is to keep
people physically apart from each other
not not anywhere in vicinity if I'm
physically apart from you I can't spread
the virus to you basic physics right but
the problem is
most people are not in a economic
situation that can Abide a lockdown
or even a social situation you can buy
the lockdown it's not it's it's inhumane
right so you're when we're actually
built to be in community with each other
to talk to each other to be so
interested and so that even even rich
people have that need
um but poor people they need to work in
order to feed their families they need
to work to they need to like they they
need to be in society in order to have
the most basic functions uh many live in
Cross in poor countries live in crowded
living situations that's just a fact
about the way the world is
um you can't have a lockdown that
lockdown will end up
impoverishing people that lockdown will
end up throwing people into into food
dot you know start near starvation
that's actually what happened 100
million people is the estimate thrown
into poverty worldwide by the economic
dislocation caused by the lockdown you
know those Supply chains well the pointy
end of the supply chains is some guy in
in Ghana who's barely holding on losing
his job
and now he's making less than two
dollars a day of income he can't feed
his kids some of his kids starve
um there's one estimate from March of
2021 out of the U.N that 230 000
children had died in South Asia alone
from the lockdown the economic
dislocation caused causing starvation in
by the lockdowns
um that and and the and and uh stopping
of of basic immunization I mean it's uh
it was bound to have that effect it was
bound to destroy the lives of the poor
the working class the you know it is and
children it's exactly what it did
because in many ways what it did is it
favored big business
it favored you know these huge
multinational corporations and it also
favored the laptop class because they
were the ones insulated from it because
they could still work they could still
everything they needed to do and in fact
they could save money because they
didn't have to travel anywhere you know
they could get discounts on their rent
but the working classes they still had
to go and do their job
your your apps that's exactly right I
mean I've called it uh trickle-down
epidemiology the idea is that I mean
it's like if we just protect the laptop
class everyone else would be protected
by osmosis or something it you know to
work worked exactly how you'd expect it
to work
um I I think um
a lot of the people that made these
policies they they moralized it right
there there they are
a class of people that could be
protected by a lot like for me I just I
I'm a professor I didn't have to I could
have worked from home the entire time
would have been fine I wouldn't have
lost my job I actually couldn't abide
that I I went to work but
um but a lot of the a lot of this a lot
of the people that were in this they
moralized it stay home stay safe right
you you had that in the UK what the heck
is that message that message is like
well if I'm not able to stay home
because I have to feed my family I'm not
I'm not I'm like endangering the
community
that's a terrible message to send to to
the to a community to the vast numbers
of people that actually couldn't stay
home and stay safe just because of basic
uh you know basic economic reasons um so
I just I think um it's it's it's it's
that deep inequality and then this like
valorization of of being rich enough or
having the resources to be able to to
comply with the orders and then even
there you still had like you know like
Matt Hancock violating them Boris
Johnson violating them like in in where
I live uh uh Gavin Newsom having this
French Laundry dinner
um
I mean actually frankly whenever I saw
that I would celebrate not not because
of the hypocrisy of it although there
was a little bit of that I have to admit
um but but but also because uh you know
people being human it's fine it's like I
just it's just a reminder that everybody
needs to be needs connection
Jay let me explore you know the Devil's
Advocate counter arguments here because
uh there are a lot of people who
supported the lockdowns who would say
well look if we hadn't kept people
physically apart from each other to some
extent obviously it wasn't 100 but if we
hadn't reduced a number of people the
average person came into contact the
disease would have spread faster it
would have spread to more people we
didn't have a vaccine at the time and
the health care services which were
already struggling I mean the NHS people
don't know this but like there's
newspaper headlines from every year over
the last 20 years saying the NHS is
about to collapse winter crisis so the
flu blah blah blah so you take that you
add on top of that this highly
infectious disease that no one really
knows wasn't it the right decision based
on all those inputs to go let's keep
people apart let's reduce the spread and
let's make sure our Health Care system
is going to cope you know we built some
hospitals we didn't have the staff to
put in them but we build the hospitals
that do you see what I'm saying yeah no
I do I do I do constantly so so like the
key thing is there is um and there's
some Force to that argument so I don't
think the right thing to do is to do
nothing I don't think that the argument
the right argument is to let the virus
rip because exactly what you said would
happen would happen
um the the right thing to do is focus
protection on the most high-risk people
that were likely to go to the hospital
right so just uh just to give you an
example in New York uh Governor Cuomo
sent covet infected patients to nursing
homes
even though their older people were the
highest risk of being hospitalized if
they get coveted why did he do that he
was not because he's an evil guy the
reason he did that is because the
epidemiologists were telling him that
you have to open hospital beds or people
will die from from overcrowded hospital
beds that was focused protection
um on the wrong population if he had
understood that older people were the
most likely to be hospitalized then he
would never have done that he would
never have sent older people uh put the
older people at highest risk so if you
want to protect Hospital Systems you
protect older people because that's who
that's the highest risk
by by doing a focus protection approach
you you minimize the risk of the the
hospitals overcrowding If instead you do
a lockdown
the Z is going to spread anyways right
you maybe maybe you delay for short time
but not for that long like you're like
in Toronto the during the earliest
lockdowns the 30 richest neighborhoods
saw no case spread the 30 poorest
neighborhoods had enormous outbreak
um that was repeated everywhere you saw
a lockdown the the lockdown was focused
protection of the laptop class
instead of focused protection of the of
the of the vulnerable old and that's why
Hospital systems were under stress
because we've protected the wrong people
that now that that does make a lot of
sense to me uh and uh coming to the
conversation about the vaccine you you
will know as you alluded to that there
are a lot of people who are who've got a
lot of questions about it uh who are
concerned about it what is your
assessment of the safety and efficacy of
the vaccines that we currently have at
the moment
so let me start with efficacy because
that's that's what I think um probably
the most important thing
um I think uh and and let me just start
I mean I'd say safety is quite important
well I'll be okay but you're both you're
they're both important actually can I
can I start with can I move to start
with the conversation with uh with
immunity more generally because I think
it's this is this is a key point that a
lot of people when they talk about the
vaccine they miss
um if you've had covet and recovered you
actually have pretty substantial
immunity right before Omicron something
like point three percent who had been
infected there's a big study out of
Italy
um the hundreds of thousands of people
uh that it infected were reinfected
point three percent three out of a
thousand it's very substantial immunity
against reinfection until there's a new
variant
and then the other thing is if you have
uh infection and you recovered you
actually have pretty substantial
immunity against uh severe disease on
re-infection
um there's a study out of Israel
suggesting that you're 10 times more ten
times better protection than the vaccine
now I'm not saying I'm not arguing that
you should have gone out and gotten
infected intentionally but but the fact
is so many people have been infected and
recovered you know I think the United
States is above 90 percent of the
population same in the UK
um
so that changes the landscape about the
efficacy of the vaccine
if you already I'm sorry to interrupt uh
did you just did you say that over 90 of
people have had covered in the US and
the UK yeah
really yeah basically wow I didn't know
that okay sorry uh please carry on yeah
I mean it could be you could you could
convince me 85 I mean we could argue
about the about the exact numbers but
like you know I just hadn't heard that
that's all please go ahead yeah so what
that means is that uh that that uh it's
a very different population that than in
March of 2020 which was completely
immune naive and in that in that
population that lastly naive the
efficacy the marginal efficacy of the
vaccine against severe diseases is less
important now there's still maybe
populations that are Force important
again Focus protection older people
who've not had the disease that that are
higher risk
um you know there's still maybe other
other populations
um so I'm not saying don't it has no use
but it's it's much more limited than it
was in December of 2020 when the vaccine
first arrived
um the vaccine itself
um the it's because it was designed for
the the old the you know the Wuhan
strain originally now we have these
bivalent boosters boosters that are
designed for a strain that actually is
mostly on its way out
um so uh we have a it's we're sort of
chasing our tail with with that with
like exactly the the formulation of the
vaccine but all that is actually much
less important than the fact of the VAC
the vaccine itself if you're immune
naive does protect you against severe
disease and death
uh now what is that risk it's it's very
high for the old maybe not just the rule
of thumb I had before before uh before
Omicron was every uh let's say you're 50
years old point two percent mortality
from the disease this is the rule of
thumb
um and every seven years of age it
doubles so I was I was 54 it'll be 0.3
ish
um you know if you're 57 or 0.4 if
you're 64 it'll be 0.8 and you go back
down the other way by the time you're
you know you're you're both young men
it's gonna be pretty low the mortality
risk of the disease
um the uh the vaccine then is much more
important for older people who face a
very high risk if you're over 80 it's
got a very high risk of dying uh three
four five percent so it reduces it by
tenfold
really useful doesn't stop you from
getting it so it's efficacious in one
way but less efficacious than another
the the degree of efficacy at the extent
of it matters it depends on who you are
old younger people less so older people
more so
now the vaccine side effects
for young men the the MRNA vaccines
cause myocarditis at unacceptable rates
one in two thousand one in three
thousand something like that
that is too high it does and sometimes
people say well gosh it protects you
against getting covered which can also
cause myocarditis which is true
um that it also cause bronchitis but it
doesn't protect you against getting
coveted so now you face both risks you
face the risk of the vaccine myocarditis
and you face the risk of covered my
carditis
um so you know for young men it's and
you don't get a huge benefit because you
already are protected from covet by then
to being young
um so you know I just don't I don't
understand the push to vaccinate
children for instance
um because the the cost benefit just
doesn't work out it's one thing if you
have a vaccine you have to vaccinate
children in order to have the disease
stop spreading
because this vaccine doesn't do that so
what's the argument
and Jay I suppose the one thing that
whenever I hear people talk
please ignore
long covet they always ignore the people
who get covered and then become
desperately ill as a result of that so
can you Enlighten us what are the
portion of people who get covered who
were previously healthy active fit
adults and then because for a variety of
different reasons they're no longer able
to work all their their life is no
longer what it used to be yeah no I so
that's a really good question for
instance thank you for asking us so so
the key the key thing is um
uh in terms of the policy
preventing long covet means preventing
you from getting covered
um
I don't know any technology that does
that
so what we're talking about is is then
is just how do we support the people who
have this out long-term outcome
um now in terms of like who gets these
long-term outcomes in my view there's
three different categories of people I
can't give you precise numbers because
people still debating about the about
this
um but but like the three categories are
people who had a very severe acute bout
with covet they ended up in the hospital
in the ICU if you end up in the ICU
you're going to have a long time
recovery that's just the nature of the
thing
um and uh that's it's going to be hard
there's no there's no there's no sugar
coating what's best is don't end up in
the ICU how do you do that reduce the
risk of of of exposing older people to
covet before the vaccine vaccinated
older people now that we have the
vaccine
um second group
are people who uh
have these like lingering symptoms like
probably the classic one is uh you can't
smell uh Omicron doesn't seem to produce
at the same rate but like there's some
people uh so I when I got covered I lost
my sense of smell and it came back about
three weeks later I was I was absolutely
thrilled when I could smell you know
because I could smell mustard again that
was that was that was fun
um um but uh
uh some people there are maybe one one
percent less than one percent
um can't a year later can't smell
right
um there's some lingering effects like
brain fog things like that brain fog
meaning like people can't be people are
fatigued and they they have having
trouble like you know with like regular
activities in life
um people have done studies of this
where uh in order to do the to quantify
the number to answer your question
you can't just look at people who've had
covet and then ask them you have to have
a control group of people who've never
had covet because many of those symptoms
are non-specific
right I'm often tired and you know I'll
you can call it what I have as brains
maybe I brain fog know you guys I don't
know
um uh but uh but that uh that so you
have to have that control group and
studies that have a control group they
find in children
basically no difference between the set
of kids who had covered versus who
didn't three months later having one of
these like non-specific symptoms
um maybe it's like five percent report
at least one of the symptoms
um in big studies like in out of France
and elsewhere uh in in adults you see
higher rates in people who've had covert
versus the control group but it's like
seven percent versus four percent
um and it varies so I think there's
there's there's some legitimate
lingering symptoms for covet in a
relatively small group of people
um there's also a third group that um I
mean I think we've been through a
tremendously stressful time and it's
been it's you know people have been
gripped in fear over this over the not
so now hopefully not so much anymore but
over over the risk of getting this
disease
and it I think that there's a
somaticization of the symptoms
um that comes from that
it's why you see people who have not had
covid uh you know in 2020 saying like
they felt like they had long covet it's
a lot of that comes out of depression
fear anxiety
um and those are those are those are
real things I don't want to diminish
them and those are things but you have
to treat that very differently than you
treat you know I can't smell a year
later after I got coveted
um so it's it's uh so I think it's the
it's a combination of those three things
it may be in countries that have had
these lockdown policies where the fear
you're gonna because of group three
you're gonna have a much larger
infraction of it right so you don't hear
about long covet in Africa even though
covet spread all through Africa
um uh so uh I mean I think we we have to
treat it seriously we have to think
about it about about how to manage all
of all three of those groups seriously
um but you can't come to the conclusion
because there's long covid therefore we
should do lockdown the lockdown didn't
work to stop covid why would you think
it would work to stop long covet
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike
the only pleasure I get from the locals
is when we share an intimate moment as
we watch a Japanese tourist get trapped
in a tube door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you thank you space
Street
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal behind the
scenes footage of our trip to America
where we met a whole host of incredible
guests and gave ourselves terminal
indigestion we're also starting to do
monthly giveaways for locals only the
first one will be signed copies of
Andrew door's new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share memes have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
one of the things that I found very
interesting about the illness is how it
affected certain groups so for instance
my mother's Latin American and in South
America it
it really affected the population a lot
of people died it caused chaos whereas
if you look at Africa it was nowhere
near as bad and you look at you go well
obviously there's difference between
groups of people and Etc but they're
both third world countries you know and
so on and so forth so do we know the
reasons why it affected certain groups
and not others as as badly I think we're
still learning about that so like Africa
I think the probably the most important
fact is I think it's only three percent
are over the age of 65. that's why it
didn't really have it spread everywhere
you can't lock down but it didn't really
affect
um most of the population because most
of the population is Young
you know like a very large fraction
under the age of 18 excuse me uh Latin
America is older
um for one so I think that's probably
the primary reason the other thing is
like Latin I was looking at the lockdown
in Peru and my heart just broke like
they though they they they were a
massive poor population of poor folks in
Peru who were just devastated by the
lockdowns and then uh at one point they
uh they reclassified all their deaths
the excess deaths as coveted deaths and
so you're like oh well you had the
lockdown and then you reclassed and you
had all these Clover deaths anyways
because of the reclassification in fact
they were just lockdown deaths
um deaths because they had this
Draconian policy that didn't let poor
people you know go earn a living so that
they could feed their families
and Jay well I want to ask you a
slightly provocative question
um because as you know very well I'm
sure uh a lot of because so much of
Public Health policy was so difficult to
understand for people who were
attempting to think rationally who were
not experts I was trying to look at it
and go well why on Earth would you do
this this clearly doesn't make any sense
why on Earth would you do why would you
force people to take a vaccine that
doesn't stop the spread like all of this
stuff and it has produced as you alluded
to earlier a lot of people who think
there's something deeply nefarious going
on here these aren't mistaken people who
were trying to you know do their best
and maybe cover up for the fact that it
leaked from lab and Wuhan and whatever
but actually this is an attempt by the
public health establishment to take more
control of people's lives you know
permanent surveillance telling you you
know you you can't buy a train ticket if
you haven't been vaccinated and you know
we see some new stories out of places
like Canada where they do seem to sort
of be heading in that direction I read a
story today about how I think somebody
in Canada is recommending that
unvaccinated people are treated as
mental health problems that to be solved
what do you make of all of that what do
you say to those people do you agree
with them do you have an explanation of
why they're wrong like what's your take
on all of it I mean I think it's it's
complicated like there are there are
definitely people constitutions who took
advantage of the pandemic and who took
advantage like they're and they
absolutely did so like you know the
pharmaceutical companies pushed there's
a drug called Rendezvous put out by
Gilead they they was pushed really hard
on the basis of really bad evidence and
a lot of patients got it in hospital the
claims is the claim is that it may
actually harm people I I don't know if
that's true but like it's it's it's
um it certainly didn't help people it
didn't didn't solve you from uh from
dying in hospital if you took it
um
so I think uh I think that uh there are
Pharma interests that took advantage
there were politicians that took
advantage
um they were a very large number of of
Public Health uh people especially I
mean it looks like anyone with an mph on
Twitter they're just they had this like
they say like they conveyed this anxiety
don't don't don't see your family
Christmas don't don't uh don't hug your
children don't uh if you if your kids
coming from home from college put stick
them in the garage don't don't don't
don't let them anywhere near you
you you get this sense like the pop that
the the whole profession of Public
Health is filled with these
anxiety-ridden people who don't know how
to manage risk
um so I think uh
there's some aspect of of people
people's uh foibles and and uh and
economic interest did play a big role in
in this but I don't think it was the
center of it I think it was these
opportunities presented themselves and
and people did what they normally do is
they take it they they act in their own
interest
um not for any nefarious reasons because
if this it just is their own interests I
I place the central blame in public
health authority the top Public Health
authorities who argued that we had to
follow this policy or else
in all of the dominoes that came out of
that after that are just are like it it
came out of that that first Domino being
pushed
and Jay talk to me about something else
because one of the most difficult issues
kind of intellectually for me to to
think about during this whole thing is I
felt viscerally that vaccine mandates
the government saying You must inject
this thing in your body we know we knew
at the time it had side effects we knew
that it would have side effects because
all medicine does
uh I thought that that was wrong and I
can't I'm not a trained doctor or public
health official or anything like that I
just thought that that was the line the
government shouldn't cross in these kind
of situations
what are the ethics of mandatory
vaccinations uh from your perspective as
someone who understands health and
understands Public Health should it ever
happen I mean if somebody said to me in
the podcast I did what if this had like
a 90 mortality right now my facetious
counter argument is if it did everybody
would take the bloody vaccine by
themselves that's right you're
absolutely right
however you know what are the ethics is
is it as simple as what I'm saying the
government should never do that or other
circumstances where they should how do
we make these decisions as a society
okay so first let me like for vaccine
mandates
if you are mandating the vaccine you
have failed as a public health agency
because what what the that what that
means is there's a substantial number of
people who don't trust you
they don't trust you right and and so
like as a general rule you don't want to
tell people to take something that's bad
for them on net
right so the only reason why you would
ever want to do a mandate is there's a
group of part of the population who
essentially has to take one for the team
right they're you if you want to expose
them to something that's bad for them
because then it'll benefit the community
at Large
otherwise there's no purpose in this
which you said is exactly right so if
there's a 90 death rate from some
disease and there's a vaccine that gets
rid of that risk everyone will take it
with no mandate
as long as the public health agency is
trustworthy enough that you you could
you believe them right
um so I think um so the first
observation if you're requiring a
vaccine mandate the public health agency
has failed it doesn't it it doesn't have
the trusted needs from the population so
that you when you tell you when when I
tell you uh uh you know Francis this
does this vaccine is good for you
um you believe me and take it
um so like you know Sweden didn't back
had no vaccine mandate and yet
incredible uptake of the of the of the
of the vaccine because people trust the
Swedish public health agency
um okay second thing
um I I think there's a legitimate social
debate to be had about whether uh
whether if you have a vaccine that stops
disease transmission and you have a
group of people who don't want to take
it because it's bad for them whether
it's it's ethical to force them to take
it
I've seen good arguments both ways uh
and I frankly I I'm undecided about that
I think it would matter a lot about
exactly the nature of the disease and
how it spreads and it would be it would
be a complicated difficult argument to
have right um so
kids I don't think are very high risk
from covid I don't I think the vaccine
is is not worthwhile to give to Children
um but you could convince me that if
kids are super spreaders and the
vaccines stop the disease spread maybe
we can we can have it or I probably
would come down the other way because I
don't think we should ask kids to Bear
the burden of of of a disease spread but
like that that's a that's that's you
know people could differ on that mm-hmm
but we don't have a vaccine like that we
don't have a vaccine that stops disease
spread
so why did we create this like
second-class citizenship for vac for
unvaccinated people like these pariahs
it's essentially it's like I mean it's a
vaccine discrimination right like in
Canada you couldn't travel internally
you still can't come to the United
States if you're just visiting
um if you're unvaccinated what purpose
is served by that kovid's everywhere an
unvaccinated person is not unclean
that's essentially what like treating
them as lepers I have no idea and
there's no justification for it it's
just all it serves to do at this point
is undermine trust in public health
Jay uh this is uh this is actually true
and it's something that always used to
make me laugh apparently Hitler was
against vaccine mandates because he
thought it was a bit far
he's a vegan too or something I don't
know yeah
well I I think an important question
that we should ask at this point in the
interview Jay is what have been the
long-term health effects of the
because I'm seeing an excess death rate
we've got an excess death rate in this
country nobody's really talking about it
because it's uncovered mate all of it
because it's an unpleasant truth that
really nobody wants to talk about so
what has actually been the effects of
these lockdowns it's heartbreaking right
so um uh in in Europe but there was a
modeling study it was a really
interesting Milestone he said suggested
a hundred million people have skipped
cancer screening during the pandemic
a hundred million 100 million cancer
screening savings I shouldn't say people
100 million cancer screenings had been
skipped
um and uh that's going to lead to a
million people with cancer later stage
cancer that should have been picked up
then that that that they're gonna you
know often will kill them that shouldn't
have killed them so women will die with
breast cancer stage two stage three
stage four that should have been picked
up at stage one
um from Roanoke screening that didn't
happen
um that's I mean that's just one one
thing uh the the psychological effects
in the U.S
something like one in four young adults
seriously considered suicide in June of
2020.
the overhang for like anxiety and
depression is enormous I think that's
maybe it's lesser in Europe in the UK
because you guys had freedom today
earlier
um but uh the uh uh in in in we there
are like measles cases now outbreaks in
the United States because people skipped
basic immunization
um polio has come back it was on its way
out we were like this close to
eradicating polio
um in poor countries it's even worse
right in um I think Uganda
uh the estimate is that four and a half
million kids
after two years of Zoom school which is
which is ridiculous in in a country like
Uganda
um you you you they they never came back
to school
that means it's a generation of of poor
kids in Uganda will never get an
education
and will grow up grow up or it's just
like we we fueled inequality in a way
that like it's almost unimaginable
um and they will they will lead shorter
lives even it turns out like even in
rich countries um
short interruptions in school has these
like long-term negative consequences on
the lives of kids because you know they
grow up poorer
one estimate published in the gym of
Pediatrics early in the pandemic was
that just the spring closures alone have
led will lead to five and a half million
lost life years for American Kids
um the the overhang of these lockdowns
in terms of what what they've done to
our health of our society the the the
the the the the the social the social
inequality the the poverty is almost
it's almost impossible to exaggerate it
is it is catastrophic and terrible I
don't know for certain all those excess
deaths you talked to my friends that
started due to the lockdowns but I I do
believe that substantial fraction must
be
um the long tail of the lockdown arms
places and do you think oh sorry carry
on Joe no just just one one more data
point uh the uh the the lock the the in
Scandinavia the uh all cause access
death rates are actually quite low now
um you know close to zero
I mean they didn't lock down nearly as
as as much as the UK did or you or the
US did I think that that's I think that
the lockdowns will ultimately play some
role in explaining it
Joey do you think we've learned our
lessons from these mistakes or do you or
do you think we're gonna just gonna make
the same mistakes again we have not
learned our lessons for instance
um I do have some hope that we might uh
the UK there's a I think a parliamentary
inquiry that's happening on on covid and
there's still now some fight over
exactly what's going to be part of that
um I think any honest evaluation of
these policies will conclude they were a
failure and um they were disastrous
failure that has harmed the the economic
well-being the physical well-being the
psychological well-being of vast
populations any
inquiry like the Parliamentary that's
happened in the UK that doesn't conclude
that lockdowns were a disaster I think
or won't have been an honest evaluation
there's a lot of people who made these
decisions that have a strong vested
interest in making sure that these
inquiries end up saying oh everything
was fine we we did the best we could
under under
circumstances was difficult but that's
not actually right they suppressed
voices that opposed it
um they they they engaged unethical
behaviors like stoking fear in the
population using behavioral economics
techniques to do that
um they they made tremendously Bad
Decisions by closing themselves off from
criticism they employed censorship in
social media and a whole bunch of other
settings so that people couldn't
effectively push back
um so I I think
um the ultimate outcome of this needs to
be these discussions it needs to involve
people who were who were pushed aside in
the debate and I think the ultimate
outcome has to be that lockdown has to
be a dirty word we have to look whenever
we think about the word lockdown
whenever you think about the concept of
lockdown we shudder in in fear we say we
should never do this again
um that has to be the outcome of these
but I'd be very afraid that that's not
going to be the vested interests that
pushed these these policies
um that benefit from these policies
don't want it to be concluded that way
because they then my God like it's a
world historic bad thing that happened
that they did
um
um now I think the outcome should also
involve some level of forgiveness I mean
you know like this was so big a thing
it's like uh you know you you don't we
have to come together we can't like put
half the you know indict half the people
of the world that made these decisions
or very very high I mean they we have to
live with them so there has to be some
some kind of forgiveness but not until
we have a solid understanding and
acceptance that what we did was deeply
wrong
and Jay this is perhaps a strange
question to ask but
um
Francis and I were both vocal about some
of what we thought was happening going
too far uh and a lot of other people
were but do you think do you think we as
the general public I know you you and
and your colleagues were very courageous
in actually attempting to to speak up at
a time when it was difficult and you you
were demonized and not allowed to speak
on these big Tech platforms as we we had
our issues with that as well but do you
think we as the public did enough to
stand up to this did we do everything
that we could or do you think that you
know it seemed to me like there were a
lot of people who actually would have
agreed with us but just preferred to be
quiet because that that was the
direction that the government was going
I mean I think in March of 2020 it was
basically impossible I think that that
the the fear was so great that it was
very hard for public work I mean I
remember there was someone some groups
tried to organize a lockdown protest in
in local and they were just I mean
normally protesting in like you know
hippie to be California are fine but you
can't you just can't do that in March of
2020 I but I and I but I think a lot of
the uh I mean like the easy answer
constantly is that the public didn't do
enough but I don't blame the public
right you had deployed against the
public these techniques of social
control that are very difficult to to
push back against right uh if you're you
know you're censored on YouTube or
whatever well now people like distrust
me because gosh the these smart people
in in Tech think I'm saying something
crazy enough that they can't even
presented to the public at all
um that you you you you organize a
protest or something against the
lockdown and then
um all these Pub these these very smart
people say you're doing something deeply
irresponsible
um it's very difficult for the public
without expect to to to speak up and in
fact one of the reasons we wrote The
Great Barrington Declaration was to
enable the public to say look there
isn't a consensus on on the lockdown
there are legitimate people who disagree
with it and so they could speak up and
say well you know we're not crazy we're
we're we're actually
um engaging in the public fight over
over this deeply important issue and we
should have our voice heard that was
that was one of the purposes was to like
enable that to happen so that because uh
before that it's like oh yeah the entire
scientific Clarity agrees that the the
lockdowns of the way if you speak up
you're insane
um so I think um I think that it's it's
the answer to your question is yes I
think the public
um
should have spoken up more but at the
same time I don't see how they could
have spoken up given the social
pressures that were put in place to make
sure that they stayed silent
that makes sense well look we're coming
to the end of the interview so we'll ask
you our usual final question but I
wanted to give you an opportunity to
very succinctly tell everybody what we
should do next time let's say we have
another pandemic that's exactly like
covert but not covered what do we do the
key principle is focus protection
identify high-risk people move Heaven
and Earth to protect them and it might
be a different set of high-risk people
maybe it won't be elderly maybe it'll be
kids
um so you'll have to be very creative
about how to do that it's going to
require a local effort it's not going to
be one Global policy the living
circumstances in London be different
than in La than in Billings Montana
um but it's going to require creativity
focused protection of high-risk people
and then then like develop vaccines
develop treatments as rapidly as you can
that's the right way to deal with it
never lock down again do not disrupt the
lives of people that keep Society going
assuming that everyone is capable of of
of the the kinds of of uh of activities
that the uh that the laptop class made
that we have to understand that uh that
Society really is unequal and don't
trust just Deputy knowledge let's have
other people at the table let's have
let's have like uh you know it shouldn't
just be scientists these are two
complicated decisions that involve
values that scientists apparently are
incapable of seeing
Jake before there's one last question I
wanted to ask because there is now an
ebola outbreak happening in Africa at
the moment which I'm sure you're
probably well aware of does it worry you
that as a disease that kind of pandemic
where you've got a disease that is so
deadly like Ebola does that have a
chance of becoming a global pandemic I
think it's unlikely
um Ebola is is a deadly disease but it
you get symptoms fairly quickly and it's
you're very sick and so you're not going
to go around spreading it uh it spreads
in conditions where it's poor where
people are living close close contact
with people unavoidable contact
um I don't think it spreads the way that
this disease spreads this is the reason
why this disease was so highly
transmissible was because it's
aerosolized it lives in the air you
breathe it guess why Mass don't work so
well it's because you have these gaps
your glasses fog up that's aerosol
aerosolization events if you have if you
have coveted there's covet on your
glasses
um you know uh so so uh yeah I'm not so
worried about that I am worried that
that that the Ebola get managed by out
in Africa you don't want people to die
there of that disease but I think that
there we actually have pretty good tools
to try to reduce the spread of that
disease in Africa
um so yeah I'm not worried that it's
going to be a global pandemic I do think
we've to take it seriously there
well Jay thank you so much it's been an
absolute pleasure speaking with you
um and this can be completely unrelated
by the way to covet and everything we've
talked about but as always what do you
think is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
uh there's an irony in this I think
censorship kills Constantine I think
censorship is the worst and uh maybe
we're starting maybe that's not the
right answer your question because we
are talking about it it's funny that
we're we're talking about censorship um
um but we're not talking about it enough
um and I I am really glad to see Elon
Musk trying to trying to uh bring back
some voices that were silenced
um but that needs to be a society-wide
effort I thought we had a norm about
this in western western democracies that
we we didn't we didn't silence each
other we might yell at each other but we
don't silence each other
um let's bring that Norm back and we're
not talking enough about that
I agree completely well we're going to
ask you a couple of questions from our
local supporters that only they will get
to see on the locals but Dr J batter has
been an absolute pleasure thank you so
much for joining us and thank you guys
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or also all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's all it's also available
I care and see
I do worry about the side effects of the
vaccines for young men for sure
[Music]